our new dailywire comedy lady Ballers
premieres tomorrow night at 8:00 and the
response to the film has already been
huge uh I think it's on its way to
becoming you know one of the most
successful and talked about comedies in
years uh or I mean really the most um
and that's also partly because there
haven't been any real comedies in in in
years and uh you know and that's partly
because people are starved for good
comedy and also partly because people
are sick of this gender ideology Madness
and they're ready to laugh at it and
ridicule it which is what this film does
and speaking of which I did finally see
the movie last night at our red carpet
Premiere it was my first time seeing it
as I think I've already complained about
that they wouldn't let me see it ahead
of time and um in fact most of the
scenes in the film I I wasn't even there
when it was filming because I'm only my
character only shows up a few times here
and there so I went into this almost
like any other member of the audience
and I also except that I went into it
ready to rip it apart in my mind and be
hypercritical because you know that's
how I am with any creative project that
I'm involved in but I'm happy to report
that it is um the movie is very funny it
works as a a satire of gender ideology
of course but it also stands on its own
as a as a comedy and that was one of the
things I was watching for it's like yeah
it makes the point makes the point very
effectively so we want to do that you
want to make the point uh satirically
which the film does
but aside from the message aside from
the point does it just is it just funny
on its own and uh I'm happy to say that
it certainly is and it also and I mean
this as a as a
compliment but the movie is much weirder
than I thought it would be it's it's a
it's
a some very weird and kind of random
elements in the film which I like
because I have a kind of absurdest dark
sense of humor so I love that about it
re really I think the whole movie comes
across like we were trying to entertain
ourselves while making it and
entertaining everybody else is kind of a
byproduct of that which is sort of how
it went so you could tell that we're
having fun making it and uh I think that
that that makes it more enjoyable for
the audience as well and speaking of
weird stuff that we did mainly to make
each other laugh um there's my character
and I actually uh have been given
permission to play for you an exclusive
a world premiere exclusive uh clip of my
char
introduction in the film and uh in the
film I'm playing a character named Chris
who is the woke boyfriend of Jeremy's
character's
ex-wife so it's a whole thing I told you
it's weird anyway here's how that uh is
first introduced in the film let's play
the
[Music]
clip yeah
love love
[Music]
love
how are you you have a good time yeah
Daddy was okay was he late yeah he was
really late okay
okay hey
hey we need to talk thank you for
picking up Winnie Robert we're married
for 15 years Darby and call me Rob Darby
and uh Robert will do just fine coach
Rob oh good my lover former
lover
okay
okay got yep okay look at us one big
unconventional family lover I think your
transition into divorce would be
smoother if coach moved in with us
absolutely not never going to happen
well coach now that we're basically cads
I was wondering if you'd like to help me
train for the Nashville
runs $5,000 prizes my body's a sacred
Temple I'm all about physical fitness uh
bug based food Foods mRNA vaccines
Equitable and inclusive hiking there it
is my lover says you were a great coach
back in the day honey why don't you go
uh help Winnie with her
homework light and love coach light and
[Music]
love Lady B callers streaming
exclusively on daily wire plus December
1st there it is there's the Oscar
winning
performance um not the last hug that I
give in the film I can tell
you and uh there's a there's a working
Theory here at the daily wire
that uh Jeremy conceived of this whole
film just as a an excuse to get me to
hug him so I don't know if that's true
or not but I've already said
you know if this movie cost $7 million
to make I would have just given the hug
for like three million I would have half
that is all you had to
pay uh so there it is the the the whole
film is uh is uh very much worth
watching and you can watch it tomorrow
when it premieres at uh at
8:00
and I don't want to give anything away
but you
know anyone that you've ever seen
associated with the daily wire will show
up in this film at some point I can tell
you that
very much a team a team group effort hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there